again fun on the water I got this guy
earlier I actually forgot what what this
was they have black or something okay so
let's see what we get here maybe Catalan
I don't want the Catalan maybe I can go
with the ready set up keeping it more in
theme with this this week this is King
side chain check your ideas ok let's go
95 increasing the scope of my bishop ok
so maybe here feels like a place Bishop
f6 and takes on c3 anyway ok not the
capture though maybe maybe I can go here
and provoke him into go a 6 let's try
that not so clear if the nidus is well
placed on a 3 I have to admit that but
so hmm he's probably going for b6 so
anyway to cannot really prevent that but
ok I will have some some play on the B
be for them so let's double and now get
the night over to some more attractive
place that a 3 probably wasn't the best
best idea ever so um a four runs into a
check not good
yeah let's do that king is just not well
placed there running into possible
checks the whole time so a for I am
trying to do something against his pawn
structure a form where's my night going
I still don't have a good place for that
night okay i know i know where i'm going
to i have three so he opened the h far
but he's never going to do something on
it
the night only three also has ideas like
92 if for maybe are coming to be three
at some point okay so you see angling
for b5 it may be is what about 925 is
that right or I think I can go away for
actually if it takes rook a one I will
take a six I think that's actually a
good trade okay so hmm a5 b5 now but i
can check i have 94 at the end for tech
tech so he cannot really go b5 now
that's a neat low tactic yeah even in
the slowest of openings like this
sometimes tactics that are in place in
play that was neat and quite necessary
so I'm can check or not I cannot take I
have to take with that but it's also
good let's see she go hook bae don know
just the a pawn I guess let's let's put
push the airport I have evil I didn't
really look at rookie this one it really
had an idea his move should have paid
attention Wow stupid I really I really
didn't didn't look I really look Wow oh
that it's quite serious counterplay no
don't tell me that ah ah stupid
you
insane just insane just have to make a
prophylactic move and it's just over 86
how bad can you play really came
I have to check on these six sometimes
that that's important maybe so look here
I think
maybe I'm still not losing I mean it was
entirely entirely unnecessary to allow
that but maybe I'm not losing yet so
Quinn back I guess
I'm threatening rook age one now getting
rid of the rooks if I manage that it's
it's okay
don't know if 23 was so helpful
let's get rid on the rocks
keep that 195 maybe but I have 96 and 94
coming Jeff let's do that 94 194
actually for attacking c5 okay you might
check them i also have let's let's do
that first that that must be right
actually oops no I'm not even
threatening that that's cute that's cute
I didn't see that one ok but maybe here
queen is still a check and I have
queen-to-be aid and rook age 8 those
kind of ideas maybe I can actually get a
counter check going queen bee aid next
is quite nice I think let's do that i
also have from check on the seventh and
rook a jade as a threat he cannot go to
k2 and then I graduate next year and
shake it for Queen evade made check
that's made on a fate isn't it checkmate
Wow allowing the h5 counterplay was I
was one of those totally insane moments
and you really think what how I mean I
just it didn't register I was thinking
king of seven I don't know keeping e6
protected or whatever i just i simply
blanked out him and this is this is the
kind of defensive move that that
basically seals the deal if he is moving
the Queen away I like like here for
example I can do many things 90 64 or
something maybe
push this I have this move just have to
see that there's an idea I with King a 7
and not allowing this now let's see the
engine is giving Queen a2 equal equal so
at least i'm not losing but that's very
lucky that's really very lucky what
about this Queenie one wins for white
amazing what about this said also wins
so I'm really winning with this well
quite quite surprised that I was
thinking that must be must have been a
you sure you would huge mess that I that
I got into but this is in fact pretty
well played surprisingly yeah allowing
the H foul play is just bonkers yeah and
she has to avoid be fine if he plays
let's say would be seven or something
I'm slightly better because of porn
structure but it's nothing nothing
serious oh but how did I allow that age
from play amazing okay well thanks for
watching